Thank you.
Okay.
Good morning, good.
Good morning, everybody.
Welcome to the Committee of Conference on HB 1223, Creating Local Options for Games of Chance.
We're going to open up the committee, conference committee on that.
With us in the committee, we have Senators D'Alessandro, Innes, and Lange.
for the House, we have Representative Howland, Gilman, Sweeneyey and myself chairman turcutt so with that um representative lang asked the house to come to a committee of conference for some uh small language changes i'm going to let him speak to that um We will also speak to an amendment that I put forth that I'm going to just talk about, I think, between my amendment and the language, Senator Lang, I think we're pretty much there.
So I'll open the floor for you.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair, again, I apologize.
So the first change that we made was around the language.
There was some concern about voters.
In the original bill, we just had one line that says, you vote to prohibit.
And if they had voted to prohibit and they already had existing gaming, why weren't they being shut down?
And it could be confusion for voters who didn't understand what that meant.
And so what we ended up doing, asking for it and putting, is that we create two different questions.
One question, if you have no charitable gaming in your organization, shall we prohibit it?
And the other one says, shall we prohibit any additional games of chance license?
So there's two different questions that would go on a ballot, whether or not, based on what that municipality's conditions terms are.
So if they have a licensed entity in there, then they would go in there.
The section three part of the bill in your amendment and in the original amendment, there were some concerns I had around the language that was being used.
And the issue is around this.
I was treating the prohibition to be similar to zoning ordinance or planning board ordinances, is that in the planning board or zoning board, if I file an application on July 1 for an acceptable use of a piece of property, and then six months later, the town passes an ordinance saying that's no longer an acceptable use of that property, my application is still good, right?
Your application is still allowed to to go through so my concern was dealing with making sure that we're clarifying that the date of which comes first matters so if i file an application first and then the town files petition the application is still a grandfather application and not subject to the vote if the petition goes first first and the date on the petition is sooner and the application is after the fact, that application after the fact is subject to the vote.
So that's all I'm trying to make sure we're clear on in the bill is to create delineation in the language that if you have existing, then we're not adding any additional, but we're keeping what we have.
And if you don you don't have any you're prohibiting outright and the second piece was based on the action date whether the action date on the application or the action date of the municipal moving forward on a petition whichever is earlier is the overriding factor that's what i'm trying to get to thank you so the amendment that i put forth that's in front of you there, 2246H, incorporates everything that you talked about in the original language you sent to me, talks about the two questions, how they should be worded.
Those are just shortened a little bit, cleaned up from what you had.
The only difference that I see right now is if you go down to line 20, starting on line 29 at the end, where it says, or an applicant for a Games of Chance operator license applied to the lottery commission prior to september 1 that was for you um i believe the language that you sent prior to uh if we just replace that sentence with prior to the date of action in section 1a petition date or b notice date would that would you guys i think again think that meets the requirement.
The requirement is that if the application is before either what happens in Section 1 with a petition or Section 2 with the alderman, the action date of either one of those objects, if the application dates before that, then the vote won't matter to that applicant.
But if it's after that, then it will prohibit the action.
So I think that language will work just fine.
Thank you.
Does anybody have any questions or comments?
So if I had OLS redrafted with that language.
We'll sign off.
Oh, I'll have it.
Sorry, Bob.
I'll sign off.
Are you guys good with that?
Yes.
So we'll sign off oh i'll have it i'll be sorry about i'll sign off i'll sign outside um are you guys good with that yes so we'll sign off everybody here yeah yeah okay well it appears um i haven't done many of the cocs as a chair i believe all i have to do is bring this down make the change we don't have to come back here we'll just be just sign off on it we'll read it to make sure it's the intent of the committee and then we'll sign it well that was very easy then all right well with that the committee conference on hp 1223 is closed and i will make those changes and have the blurbs and everything done and you guys can sign off great thank you thank you Thank you.
Thank you.
Okay.
It is 1.30.
Welcome to the Committee of conference on hb 1215 i know others haven't done this but i want to start with the pledge of allegiance please pledge allegiance to the flag of the united states of america and to the republic for which since one nation under God, indivisible, with liberty and justice for all.
Okay, wonderful.
So we are here to discuss HB 1215 relative to development approvals and appeals and allowing the town of Hampton to discontinue a particular highway in order to lease that property.
The House the house has sent HB 1215, um, through, uh, a process that took place in the special committee on housing where we spent a year listening to various stakeholders and developers.
And, um, one of the things they indicated was the fact that, um, previous projects were approved and then, um, people went in, our town officials went in later and made more stipulations on the approval process.
So this bill, 1215, originally passed the House on the consent calendar, but I'm going to allow Representative Wallace to speak to the underlying bill first before I kick it off to the Senators.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Yes, House Bill 1215 is the culmination of about four or five years worth of work to enact some regulatory reform with respect to building permit.
Building permits, once they've been issued, in many cases, some towns would require additional provisions beyond what existing codes were in place at the time of issuance.
We cannot make law retrospectively pursuant to the New Hampshire Constitution, so consequently and similarly, the political subdivisions don't have that authority as well.
What this bill does is say that the building codes that are in effect at the time of issuance of the permit, that's the only ones that shall be considered, and the same for subdivision plats.
And it also lengthens the time with which to get substantially underway.
The COVID years really put a crush on some of the building developments here in the state.
And some subdivision approvals expired during that time, and they would not be able to be continued under the existing statutes.
They would have to comply with new design and things like that.
So this is going to put a little bit of relief to allow some further development.
It also provides for an appeals process should someone be aggrieved by this process in a town.
Not all towns have a building code review board or the people qualified and capable of deciding those types of situations.
So this would set forth a defined appeals process for that as well.
And that's in a nugget the essence of House Bill 1215 as it was originally introduced and passed both bodies on consent.
Thank you, Representative Wallace.
So the House position is to support the underlying bill, but the Senate also has amended the bill to add an amendment about discontinuing a road in Hampton.
Senator Altshuler, would you like to speak to that amendment?
thank you mr chair um the amendment in the space as amended by the Senate is on page three, beginning on line 13.
and it would empower the board of the select board in the town of Hampton to engage with the with the community on a vote to discontinue a portion of d street in the in the town of hampton which stretches from ocean boulevard to route 1a it's about 500 feet the purpose of this of this discontinuance is to engage in a possible opportunity for economic development.
We have put in, if you look on lines 22, 23, and 24, for the purpose of obtaining input regarding this discontinuance of this short road.
We have put in a public meeting with the commissioners of the Hampton Beach Village District, the commissioners of the Hampton Beach Area Commission, and the Town of Hampton Planning Board.
And then following those meetings, the Town of hampton shall hold two public hearings through the select board not more than 14 days apart at which point the select board may choose to enter into a long-term lease for the property that is d street and the lease is at the discretion of the select board, they may determine the terms of the lease, the cost of the lease, they may do they also may determine that whomever leases must also take care of any water and sewer under the road.
So that is an opportunity for the town of Hampton to engage in.
It is non-lapsing.
So if they do not take advantage of this option, it goes away.
So it's a very short-term opportunity to take advantage of a possible economic development plan.
This was brought to us by the town of Hampton as a request, and we fulfilled that request.
I do want to mention, I have heard a couple of people very concerned, people who may not be familiar with the Seacoast area, that on one side of D Street is the Hampton Beach Casino Ballroom.
And the owners of the Hampton Beach Casino Ballroom are interested in doing a refurbishing or, you know, a new project.
They also own all the property almost to the very end of D Street.
So that's all theirs on either side.
And we did get some guidance.
We did hear, here's an understanding about land owned by the town.
Going back to the 1800s, when the streets were created by the Hampton Beach Improvement Company, the deeds on one property talked about being bound by the street.
very similar to the language of laws from the 1930s, which in a nutshell says that if there is a discontinuation of a street, the abutters on either side of the street own up into the center line.
So that also is the developer who would be interested in renting D Street.
And I want to address the Hampton Beach Casino Ballroom.
Back when the Casino Ballroom was first named, casino was a word to describe an entertainment venue.
There's no gambling at the New Hampshire Casino Ballroom.
And we do have a lovely newly refurbished Ocean Gaming, which has a killer bar on the second floor with a great view of the ocean.
So just a little plug.
If you want to come down, you want to gamble in Hampton, you're not going to be able to do it at the Casino Ballroom.
So don't be disappointed.
It is not a casino, nor is there any movement to gain a casino license in that space it's just a descriptive word so i hope that clears up any confusion about there being a big casino going down to hampton beach we have ocean gaming we also have the brook in seabrook we're good thank you senator altshuler Senator Abbess, do you have anything to add?
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
During the hearing, I think my colleague said it's the town that came to the state.
And just look at who signed in support.
First big box for me was to make sure the senator from District 24 was in support of this.
You had a state representative as well that represents Hampton.
You had Nancy Stiles, who was a former state senator.
You had the Hampton town manager.
You had Bob Preston from that chamber of commerce in that area.
You had someone from the Hampton Beach Village District, someone from New Hampshire Housing, and then you had someone from the Planning Board.
So you had people from different parts of the community in the municipal government coming to the state asking for this.
So I think in regards to some concerns, for me, it's in my humble opinion, that checks all the boxes that I wouldn't want checked.
understand some people look at the procedure here but when it's the if when they come to the state you know cohesively like that um the only opposition some people uh they weren't members of the actual this is that during the hearing not during the actual hearing that we receive any opposition thank you Senator um let me rephrase it we did receive opposition but not opposition from residents of the community thank you senator is there represent power thank you mr chairman so i'd like to just briefly um further clarify that the word casino is italian for summer house and when it was um the hampton beachino Ballroom was named back when it was built in 1899, our culture was quite different.
So again, to clarify, casino is, as the historic name is, it means summer house.
But I'd also like to add, in fact, that the legislation in this amendment is a nine-month window of opportunity for the select board to exercise an option or not.
And as the senator has described, it entails two parts.
The first part is the discontinuation of D Street, and the second part is to enter into a long-term lease with the abutter of this very short road.
And in fact, the road is less than a tenth of a mile.
So I have spent a lot of time in the past week, more time than I would like to admit, researching this topic, researching the language of this amendment as it relates to our current statute.
And unfortunately, I do.
Let me just back up.
I appreciate the input that I have received as a member of this committee of conference from various people across the state.
But I do find that it's unfortunate that some of the information is, in my opinion, demonstrates misunderstandings.
So one of the things that I research very extensively was the notion, couldn't this issue at hand be resolved through a special meeting or at an annual town meeting?
And the short answer is no, it cannot.
So let me explain.
So there's two RSAs that this amendment addresses, and the first one authorizes the discontinuation of the road.
But more importantly, which I think has been missed, is the close reading and look at RSA 4111 that pertains to leasing of property, public property.
So our current statute authorizes selectmen to enter into a lease of unused public property for up to a year.
And that statute also allows for the legislative body to authorize the selectmen to enter into a lease to up to five years.
So let's just think about that.
It's very clear that there is no provision in our current RSAs that the state legislature authorizes local municipalities to to give into either the select board or the legislative body to lease public property for longer than five years clearly to me as a member in the vice chair of municipal and county government this language is a deficiency in our statute.
And it's deficient for any economic, any development project in our state.
So again, to be clear, a five-year lease, even if it's renewable, it just simply cannot justify an investment of any substance with regards to time, the planning, the resources, and the capital, with the near-term possibility that a lease might not be renewed.
So furthermore, as a practical matter, a lease, when we're talking about development projects again of any significance in terms of of size and capital it requires a lease longer than one year or up to five years so to me in in based on my analysis of the the facts at hand, our statutes are deficient.
So to summarize what I'm saying here is that current RSA doesn't authorize long-term leases.
And to reiterate, the part of leasing, this land cannot be accomplished at a special town meeting nor at an annual town meeting.
And that's why this language in this amendment is needed and it's justified.
And the last thing that I will say is the reason that we are here where we are today in a committee of conference is due to the fact where this deficiency was brought to the legislature's attention.
It has to do with where we are in the legislative calendar.
If this occurred after January, then it would have been a move for a late late filing of legislation if this occurred before crossover it would have been an amendment to a bill in either either body you know the as it turns out that this was brought to our attention after crossover therefore it it it was an amendment to to a house bill.
And that's why we're here in Committee of Conference.
And the last thing that I'll say is, you know, it could have been a floor amendment, but it wasn't.
So this is why we're here.
We're the legislature.
And when we find deficiencies in statute.
This is we, we, we, we correct them, we deal with it through legislation.
And that's all I'll say for now.
Thank you, represent power, Senator Abbess.
Thank you for that explanation.
I, and I will say, for the people that are listening, this development would basically go over the entire road.
So the road wouldn't still be there in its physical form as it is today.
So I think the problem that any developer, and take this out of it, no one is ever going to get financing to develop anything significant if your security interest is only protected for five years and unless that note has to be paid you know it would be a short term no that's it so to do something major it just i don't think it would ever happen unless you just did it with in cash which is a tall ask and who would you want to do that knowing in five years what would happen if the lease was not renewed i mean there's a you're building you have this large structure is now over the road so just the practicality of what what we're dealing with i think you outlined very well wouldn't work under the current rsa's and maybe in a future legislative we'll look at that five-year minimum and maybe discuss the flexibilities but thank you senator um represent de lorenzo do you have anything to add I just have a concern I've gotten letters and emails from different entities stating that um if this deal goes through it would set a precedent um for other deals so I just like someone to address that for me please thank you represent our senator rabbits so I had i had the same concern as you and that's why i talked about the the boxes to check the first thing i said well hampton's not my district so before i start thinking about that i should see what my friend here wants to do well she was the one filing so that oh easy what did the state what did the state rep wants wants to do one of them signed in support of it i haven't heard any objection from the other state reps i think there's four for hampton right correct so i haven't heard any opposition there and then all right well what is what does the local government have to say there's obviously some impacts there and that's why to me the first thing i went to was you had someone from the planning board, you had someone from the Hampton Beach Village District, the town manager, they all came, they supported.
I know that the town manager came in person and testified.
So it checked all those boxes.
Now, to me, all we're doing is enabling this.
It's not guaranteeing it.
I mean, I think the people at the local level will have at least three hearings, if not more, to go over this.
This is something that's already been before the planning board in Hampton already.
So they're going to have plenty of opportunities to voice their objection.
But I think just giving that town the opportunity when it's the town coming to us, I think if it was the reverse, I wouldn't be comfortable doing that.
I think coming to us is the key for me.
Go um i'm hearing also that this is just turn your mic on i'm hearing also that um this deal is um eminent domain could you speak to that yeah that's not correct because there's no change in that's when i think the government acquires ownership of the property and that's not happening here it would be leased and they would they would be acquired the government acquiring private property so in this case it's a private so it's kind of the reverse senator altshuler uh yeah i'm i'm glad you brought that up so that we have a chance to address it publicly um eminent domain does not apply in this particular instance instance it is an option for the select board so for the elected representatives of the town to enter into a lease not a sale um nor are they taking um and um some of the i i have also received some of that some of those letters and.
About what what kind of a precedent might this set and it's it's it's useful to remember that the legislature serves the communities, and this isn't this is a a particular a legislative item that has an expiration date for this community and just this year we have also done a one-off if you will where we are backfilling the tax revenue that the town of Hampstead is losing because the state purchased Hampstead Hospital.
So that's not going to be an ongoing budget item for the state, but you know that is a one-off.
We have also done this for a local fire village district.
So we there are there are times when municipalities will come to the legislature with a specific ask that is lapsing.
You know, it's for a specific item for a specific time.
This is one of those.
Thank you, Senator.
I think you hit the nail on the head by saying that it's not establishing a new precedent.
The precedent is already there in specific targeted situations.
And I think this will go a long way in helping the economic viability of Hampton Beach, but not like the seacoast area in general.
So does that answer your question?
Yes, thank you.
Okay.
So at this point, I'm going to ask the house conferees, are we prepared to accede to the Senate position?
Representative DiLorenzo?
Yes.
Okay.
So with that, the House will accede to the Senate position.
I'm going to have Representative Wallace write the report, if that is okay.
Put you on the spot.
We can collaborate.
We'll collaborate.
I have a couple reports, so we'll collaborate on this.
Well played, Mr.
Chairman.
All right, thank you.
We.
All right.
Thank you.
We are all set.
Good morning.
Welcome to the good afternoon.
Good afternoon.
Okay.
Welcome to the Committee of Conference on HB 1400.
I'm going to recess this Committee of Conference for 15 minutes.
We're waiting for Senator Bradley.
Thank you.
Break not recess.
I'm going on a break.
Thank you.
okay okay yes Okay.
Can we have one more minute?
Yes.
Welcome back to the Committee of Conference on HB 1400.
We're going to get started with the Pledge of Allegiance.
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States of America, and to the republic for which it stands, one nation, under God, indivisible, with liberty and justice for all.
You turn it up on the road, so...
Yeah, maybe it's...
Go ahead, turn up the thermostat a little bit.
If you don't have your coat on, I think that's okay, but I think Senator Perkins-Quok can make that motion or whatever.
Okay, so welcome to the Committee of Conference on HB 1400.
So HB 1400 was assigned originally to the House Special Committee on Housing.
We heard from various stakeholders that parking is an inhibitor to the development and approvals.
The House kind of took the position of one parking space because we strongly feel that developers will put in sufficient parking for each unit.
So that position has passed the House twice now.
So with that, I'm going to kick it off and let the Senate discuss what they have added to HB 1400.
And then we have two amendments for the Senate to consider.
our position and and Senator Bradley can add in if it's like, is two spaces.
So I've talked to, I can't tell you how many people have called me on this from my 12 towns, selectmen, planning boards.
They really just want to keep it in their own hands.
They're really not happy that we're taking it out.
They think they know their communities best.
But upon looking at the whole thing, you know, we went from zero to four spaces.
We thought two is adequate.
I look down, I'm quite often in Florida, and I see most of the places are condo developments there.
They usually have a single bedroom and two.
They tend to build always two spaces.
And especially in my communities, my 12 towns, we are traveling communities who use cars.
We're not like Senator Quokas, Portsmouth.
Everyone is using a car.
So if you have usually a single bedroom is going to have two people on average.
Sometimes you're going to have more.
You're going to have high school kids.
So you could be adding a third.
There's going to be needs for other people.
You're going to have visitors and stuff.
So we thought our compromise position of two was a good unit but we're willing to read what you have new to us today and senator perkins kolka yeah just to finish answering your question chair um the senate has added language concerning squatters which was developed in coordination between the landlordslords Association and New Hampshire legal assistance um and then also the content of SB 538 my affectionately named home to bus um as passed by the Senate which includes a couple housing related policies wonderful so um the house has two amendments for the Senate to consider.
Small changes to those three things, but I think that we're moving in the direction.
Hopefully you can move over.
But with that, I'm going to call Representative McWilliams to introduce her amendment 2257 each.
Thank you, Chairander um we are looking at uh this is 2024 2257 h is the proposed amendment uh it's got today's date on it um i'd like to introduce specifically lines one through eight so this is a compromise on the house side where we originally said one unit, one parking space, which is what we passed and what we felt strongly about.
this is parsing it out a little bit more and specifically for multi-family but to be very clear that the intent here is to be equitable and not create too much parking too much asphalt too much required parking is limiting the amount of housing that we can fit in areas that already have infrastructure for housing so this parses it out to say that municipalities may not require more than one parking space for a single-family residence with one bedroom or less municipalities may not require more than two parking spaces for a single-family residence with two or more bedrooms so we're allowing the two there and i think that that may have been the concern to go one unit to two parking spaces we're hoping to cover that further this is where we get into the multi-family so municipalities may not require more than one parking space for a building containing two or more units for those units that are either a studio or a one-bedroom unit and then municipalities may not require more than 1.5 parking spaces for buildings containing two or more units for those units that contain two or more bedrooms and this is really where there's the equity of scale where if we have a hundred unit building and it's all two bedrooms that would mean 150 parking spaces for the hundred units two bedrooms and this is parking for the people who are occupying these units I'm not talking about guest parking I'm talking about parking for residents so that's the proposal and I just wanted to speak specifically to parking did you want to go further chair um I senator Gannon if you'd like speak to parking could I ask you a few questions do you know how many cars there are in new hampshire versus how many citizens oh that's a great question i don't just be something i'd know if i was so i i don't know but i'm under the when i look in my neighborhoods i never see if there's two people in the house there's always two or more cars the kids have cars i would argue but i don't know as a fact that there are probably as many cars in new hampshire as there are people so i really am leery of when you have studios in one bedrooms i look at my son and his girlfriend are going to be in a studio or one bedroom they're going to have two cars um and i see that especially in our communities we're not were mostly at least again, I represent towns mostly with single family homes.
And it's at least one car, if not more, per person in the home.
You know, I might be open to the studio part.
I might consider I just read it for the first time.
But anything beyond that, I would see a need for two spaces.
let's see you have the number of cars and so do you know how many people in an average apartment building between how many people usually live per apartment there must be so many units of apartments in new hampshire and you you probably know how many people live in each unit so i think your your question on average i, I'll clarify.
I'm sorry, I was just thinking about it.
So how many people on average live in an apartment?
There must be an average, is it two people, three people?
It's a little over one, it's like 1.2.
Per apartment, is that just for studios?
One bedrooms or two?
No, it's not taking into account number of bedrooms, it's just, if it's an apartment, the number is like 1.2 ish.
So it's slightly over one.
And that's really the challenge with housing in New Hampshire is that when we look at the actual occupancy, both on the apartment side, as well as single family residential, the numbers are actually fairly low.
Single family residential, it's more like 1.5 in a single family residential home.
Apartments, it's like 1.2.
So, yes, I hear what you're saying on the CARS piece.
And I think that's probably data that we could find from DES if you're interested.
I know that they've been tracking all the registrations to figure out if we needed to increase our registration fees.
So, I think we can get that data fairly But in terms of what is required by the municipality versus what is needed by the owner and user of the building, that's where the tension happens.
So a municipality is absolutely within their rights to say no street parking.
And then it is on the property owner, property occupant, to figure out their parking situation, right?
So we put it back on them and if they need to figure out where they're going to fit the cars or if they need to upgrade to a larger home with more parking that's putting it back on the owner of the property the alternative is the owner of the property has more rights when we reduce these parking mandates they have more rights to if they decide they need to build build an addition on their home, right?
Because if you have two parking spaces, that's the size of a studio apartment.
And I'm not saying that everybody who has a house wants to put a studio apartment ADU next to it, but when we have these parking mandates that require so much asphalt, and the person who owns the house absolutely needs that, but they would have to ask for variance to get past the town requirement that's where we run into these stumbling blocks for development so the idea is to clear and be consistent at a state level across the board but i'm happy to get you some more data on the number of cars i think i understand your amendment thank you so the house takes a position that we believe the free market is the best decider about how much parking is needed.
But this does give municipalities the right to require to for single family residences.
So I believe that that will still preserve that sort of single family residence kind of vibe that you're referring to, Senator Gannon.
So do you have anything?
I would just add for anecdotal evidence, i live in one of those apartment buildings in the state in salem new hampshire uh our parking requirement i think they built out 1.8 spots for every unit uh and there's always 60 to 75 empty parking spaces a night in a fully rented out building that was required for them to build by the town that space could have been other retail other more housing units so it's not just about the expansion of residential but it's just the ability for developers to develop on their own land any type of entity that they could that's currently being required to be unutilized asphalt okay can we take a couple minutes?
Yes.
Okay, thank you.
We're on a break.
Okay.
Thank you.
And thanks for consideration of this amendment.
I think it is hopefully a compromise that you folks can live with.
I think we all come from different areas of the state.
I represent towns and local control in towns is really important, which is why when this bill came over, it was my idea.
I spoke with Senator Gannon, members of the Commerce Committee to go to two spaces.
Understanding that parking is an issue, I think you eloquently described the problem.
We get that, okay?
But we also have to answer to, you know, folks in our towns that think they have a better handle on what their town, our towns, need than a one-size-fits-all.
So we tried to narrow this down specifically to small units, whether it's a studio or a one-bedroom, and trigger workforce housing so that it would be an incentive, if you will, to build more workforce housing because you would get this 1.5 parking space incentive for workforce housing.
And it will require, you know, the two residential spaces for anything else.
So I think that's something I can live with representing, you know, whatever it is, 18, 21 towns, I think, and no cities.
So I get the pressure, but I think this is a step-by-step approach, and we've done, you know, a lot of things for housing over the years, no one more so than me with the Affordable Housing Fund.
Obviously, Senator Perkins Quokka has done a huge amount, you know, with bills in the last session this session um i i would hope that this is a compromise that you folks can accept um thank you senator the one one of the issues we have with this amendment is the last part by defining shall not require more than two residential parking spaces uh we we feel like it sets it almost sets sets towns back because there are some towns that are doing 1.5 or one space.
So by even putting in two, I feel like it'll incentivize them to move back to two spaces.
And that's not something we want.
So we would certainly want to scratch right after RSA 67458 and just not define that at all.
I want to know what the other House members think.
Go ahead.
Senator, what if we made this just a conversation on the multifamily units and struck out single family from this?
So that was all single family regulations could be left up to the towns in question to preserve that local control.
And the state mandates would just be those last two lines of what Representative McWilliams put forward, that one parking space for a building containing two or more units for those units, and then the 1.5 parking spaces for buildings containing two or more units for those units that contain two or more bedrooms.
So just strike away the single family from the equation so i think a lot of the towns that we represent will be off the the table and off the hook in the single family neighborhoods and just focus on the multi-family which is really where the problem lies and i get that i guess i would respond by saying that even towns like mine and i represent wolfburnboro and Conway, okay, two of the largest towns in my district.
So Conway has a lot of multifamily housing.
So does Wolfboro.
Some of the smaller towns that I represent probably have less on a per capita basis.
But I still think that the local control issue and knowing, you know, in the case of Conway, I mean, and Wolfboro, parking is a huge problem.
I don't know if you've ever gotten caught on Route 16 or Route 28 in Wolfboro, but parking and traffic is a huge problem.
So I think our approach is not as aggressive as yours.
I admit that.
But I think we can get to where we need to get in a bill that will pass.
Now, I would want to go back, and if you want to strike the, you know, I guess you'd put a period after 674-48-4.
I want to, you know, talk to attorneys and see what that means if by virtue of doing that it doesn't undermine the requirement of the two spaces so as long as it because I thought the house position was you didn't want to have, you know, an upper limit.
So that's why we proposed too.
But maybe we could strike that and leave it at the period after 674.
And I think what Representative Sweeney is getting to is multifamily units, but that could be like multifamily units over four or something like that, where that's the larger developments would be like Representative Sweeney was alluding to would be the ones where they would be able to regulate the spaces to 1.5.
So we're certainly willing to allow towns to regulate single family residences however they see fit.
But if there are multifamily developments in Conway or Wolf or salem or wherever um we can talk about 1.5 spaces as being the middle ground there that's kind of where we're at just clarify for me i'm sorry i must have missed it so if i have a two bedroom in seabrook it's going to have how many spaces well bedroom in a multi-unit apartment building I would say as many as the town because we would only regulate units over four over five they can make it be two if you have 10 units of two bedrooms you would still be able to have two spaces per unit yeah because this would only affect right um I think it's really great we're having this conversation conversation.
I think it's really important.
You know, I just want to remind everyone this was this was the issue we heard about at every housing forum this fall.
I think it's I think it's really needed.
There are so many young people in the state who need a place to live and they will figure out their parking situation.
Right.
So so this is a great start.
I think it would be great if we could think about what's been sort of suggested in response.
I also will say, I think adding in the workforce housing concept is interesting, right?
Because there's some discomfort what to do with one bedrooms.
And so what we want to see is that young people have a place in the state that they can afford we want to see this workforce housing come to the table this does have the economic effect of creating a real incentive for developers to include those units and part of why they don't include them now is because when they do their pro forma for their investors they can only afford to put in so many below market rate units to make the numbers work.
I think taking out some parking spaces could really help with those economics.
So I really think it's worth thinking about.
And I agree with the comments on single family and multifamily.
For me, we are not trying to change what happens in a subdivision with you know 20 single family homes i don't think that's where this is going to have an impact i really think it's going to be in multi-family development so maybe there's some room for further compromise there do you guys want to talk for everyone so i also know that um the landlord association and i see obviously miss mckinney and elliott um is nick here all right so has that language been proposed anywhere an amendment to the squatter piece.
So do we have that?
We yes, we have further in the McWilliams amendment.
We have that language.
We were mainly just talking about parking because that was the House position is to move on that.
So we're happy to entertain other parts of the bill as well.
But at the end of the day, our strong push is the parking piece of it.
And I know that the landlord and tenants' rights advocates really worked hard on this language, and we'd like to move forward with that as well.
Yeah, I agree.
I just want to make sure it's captured.
Yes, we have it.
Okay, all right.
So do we want to put a pin in parking for now and come back to it and move on to landlord tenant squatters rights or do we want to hash out parking and be done because I think we could go either way at this point I think we would need to take another break again to I mean if your proposal is to accept our language and put a period after 674-58-4, I just want to understand what striking the two residential parking spaces does to the bill.
That's all.
So I need to talk to some people.
So maybe we could.
Well, I i think that's part of it but i think we also wanted to talk about multi-family units of like five or more in the excessive parking that's required for those units so um we're not we don't want to regulate single family maybe two three four but once we start getting to five or more or ten or more i think that we'd like to see 1.5 spaces.
So also consider that.
So that's your proposal.
10 or more, I think that we'd like to see 1.5 spaces.
So also consider that.
So that's your proposal, 10 or more multifamily 1.5.
All right.
Why don't, if we, time is kind of short because we have less than 24 hours and I know I have three or four big COCs tomorrow.
So let's keep going for a while and see if we can get there.
Senator and Chairman, I would just like to, I'm for five or more units at 1.5 per unit, not the 10, five or more units.
Well, maybe there's a compromise somewhere in there.
Okay.
So with that, Senator, would you like to- The five is is not an it doesn't multiply correctly 10 does gotcha so just to be clear they fall under different building codes um the five or more units versus the four and under they're two different building codes if you have five you're at 7.5 space you round up to eight yeah okay do you want to move on to squatters or we take a break why don't we take break all right we'll take a break Thank you.
Thank you.
Okay, welcome back.
Um, I think.
Does the Senate have a proposal for us?
So, I think we would accept.
He's new.
I know.
I just want to keep you guys sweating like me.
He doesn't have much time left to pick this up.
I know.
All right.
So I think that we would propose back to you language that said uh after rsa 674-584 and shall not require more than 1.5 residential parking spaces per unit for multi-family developments of 10 units or more just to be, so single family houses up the way to nine units is left to the towns to regulate.
I could live with that.
We're okay with that.
Good.
Drama's over, right?
What's that?
I said the drama's done, right?
Squad.
We're on squad.
So with that, I'm going to call on Representative Mannion.
He's going to chat about the squatter amendment that we have proposed.
I believe that was a request of tenants' rights people, but go ahead, Representative Mannion.
Thank you.
So first I'm going to speak on the amendment that Rep.
McWilliams put forward, the 2257H.
Lines 22 and 23 have to do with squatters, so I want to just cover that.
It says, nothing in this section shall be construed to prevent the arrest and prosecution of a person or persons pursuant to RSA 635-1 or RSA 635-2, which is burglary and criminal trespass.
I think it's important to put that in there so there's no confusion with law enforcement that this doesn't apply to those things.
Yeah, where are you?
Rep.
McWilliams' proposed amendment that was handed out today, it's number 2024-2257H.
Yeah, okay.
Thank you.
So this is the criminal trespass section?
In burglary statute, yes.
So this is the language that you folks have okayed.
Got it.
And the reason the rest is in bold is that that's part of the existing Senate position in the amendment.
Okay.
So with that, I have this lovely Mannion Amendment, which has been handwritten and marked up.
It says Mannion Amendment on top.
There's no number.
Yeah, so it hasn't actually been made an amendment yet but um so one of the concerns i saw with this with this was that it actually technically made squatting legal in private homes your private primary residence because if you come home from a vacation and find somebody in your house this adds non-rental units to that language, meaning your house.
You have to wait 48 hours before you can take any action.
You have to pay a sheriff fees, and only a sheriff can take action of it.
So what I proposed was striking any language that said non-rental owner.
If it's a non-rental owner, I don't think it should be in the 540 statute that deals with tenants and landlords.
I don't think it has any business in there.
But what would happen is if I go to a home, I've been in law enforcement for 30 years, somebody says someone's in my house, I go there and the guy says, oh, I've been here for two weeks.
I've been living here.
We have an oral agreement.
That was going to basically make burglary and criminal trespass a non-enforceable law because we'll now have to follow this and give them 48 hours for a court date and whatnot.
So I think we should exclude non-rental owner.
And the reason why I say that is specifically on page 2, lines 16 through 19, it says if the property of the personal residence is the personal residence of the non-rental owner.
That tells me that a non-rental owner can also be the homeowner, your home, your personal home, or your vacation home.
So you come home from vacation, your family wants to go in the house, and they can't.
They're told to go get a hotel room for 48 hours and go to the court and file.
So I think removing primary residences or vacation homes that are not rental units is important.
I believe I hit all the marks on there.
Yep, and I think the only other change is on page 3, line 4.
We scratched out Venmo because we don't like to refer to specific companies but uh we remained in ach and eft payments so our other electronic direct payment methods which is um which covers venmo go ahead so representative i think i agree with you?
have nick norman and elliott and uh dawn had a chance to review this i don't know that they have mr barry you can come up to the mic if you'd like.
You're welcome.
Just turn the mic on if you could.
Thank you.
What we were trying to do with non-rental owner was to make clear that you could summarily remove the occupant in a non-renter owner situation without having to go through a criminal process.
It would basically be up to the owner, basically, whether they just, if they just want them out, they could use the non-rental owner provision to do so um but i again i just need a little time i think to to look at the uh effect of the changes here if if um but yeah go ahead can i just ask one clarifying question go ahead um i just want to make sure i'm following the concern when i'm reading this it just 11 and 12, it just says to me, in cases in which a landlord or non-rental owner alleges a violation, a hearing shall be held within 48 hours.
So I guess procedurally, I'm just trying to understand, does the hearing have to take place before the person is removed?
Because your concern is that you come home from vacation, there's a person in your home and they can't be removed.
I guess just trying to talk that through.
Yeah, that's correct.
For those that don't do this regularly.
So they can remain on the property until a hearing is had.
So you would have to get yourself a hotel room and worry about all your property in your house, your personal effects, your photos, your money, your firearms, your personal property.
It could be ransacked, it could be stolen, it could be pawned or whatever in that 48-hour period.
So there's really no protection.
That, to me, sounds like non-rental owner is your primary residence, and it actually specifically points to that in some of this language.
So this is actually making squatting technically legal for the time period that we're in there and then an additional 48 hours yeah thank you for clarifying that if i may just to be clear i think the intention between what you're articulating and what we were trying to do is consistent we're fine um i just want to if if there's a way i could just pour over this language for five minutes if you care what we mr barry we're we're gonna move on to other parts of the bill and then we'll come back to this but i think we might be at a point where we can agree on it so hopefully um great yeah we'll give you some time to look into that Thank you.
It's like Rick to review it.
Yeah.
Okay.
Do we want to seem right?
Intense.
Okay.
Yep, so let's move on to...
Back to the McWilliams Amendment.
We're moving on to the home to bust piece of it.
We have...
Three changes that we would like to make.
Okay.
One iscwilliams amendment 2257h it's at the end of page one line 30 it starts as nothing in this section shall affect the governing or legislative bodies existing consultation process with the planning board that's just to make clear that if a town has an existing process they can go by that process as well yeah and if i may chair just a comment i know this was a concern that was raised on the house side i i might place it in a slightly different place but i'm i'm totally fine with the substance of this okay okay um the other change is to um repeal um rs section we have a sunset on the 79 portion of 10 years so once it takes effect the 79 e would address the current housing crisis we're in but then after that it would enable the towns the towns for only 10 years, and then after that, we'd have to either expand it to longer or it sunsets out.
Got it.
I believe those are two changes to that.
And then the parking would be consistent with the parking we discussed.
That was the third portion of your bill was related to parking.
So I believe, correct me if I'm wrong, did we remove that part of the home to bus from the amendment?
Okay, so that part remains in as is.
Okay.
Yeah, so we're going to take 10 minutes i want to um discuss with our council uh the impact especially of the your amendment sir and uh I suspect Mr.
barry's already out analyzing it okay so so we will take ten yep okay thanks Thank you.
Thank you.
Okay, we are back.
I think the proposal from was the Manning Amendment.
Senator Bradley, would you like to speak to that?
Sure.
I think after having our attorney look at it, who helped draft the squatter language and worked with a lot of other folks feels, and I think he's conveyed it to you representative, it's unnecessary, but suggests that we add the following language.
Nothing in this act shall be construed to extinguish any common law remedies, including self-help available to a non-rental owner.
Now, I apologize that it's written on the back of one of your pink cards, but I think given, you know, the consensus that we've tried to establish on, you know, the squatter amendment, that this is probably the best way to go.
So I'm not sure agree with that but you know that's why i wanted to have attorney layman um advise us because he was instrumental in drafting represent me yeah i'm still confused as to why any of this even needs to be in language that deals with tenants and landlords if it's non-rental units my primary home um i see confusion down the road with sheriff's departments of law enforcement saying that this is the this is the avenue you have to take we can't arrest the person you have to go to a court and get a hearing i i think what the i think what the the housing providers are specifically looking for is the fact that in a case where law enforcement will not enforce the existing criminal trespass, they are able to use this remedy that we are creating here, the 48-hour piece.
But I believe that the Williams Amendment, specifically section 22, or line 22-23 of page one, addresses the fact that law enforcement can continue to enforce it.
But in situations where they don't, they have this remedy available.
And I think strengthening it by adding the language that attorney layman proposed is the path forward for the committee in this way.
All right, and I'm just thinking out loud here.
What if there was language in there to indicate that in the case where law enforcement isn't able to or doesn't take action, these are the remedies?
I don't know if that would work, if that would make it worse.
I'm just kind of thinking out loud here.
So that it's clear in the beginning that you may seek relief if you're not, if a remedy isn't sought with law enforcement.
Isn't that what Representative McWilliams' amendment does when it says nothing in this section shall be construed I mean that was the intent of it so nothing will prevent the arrest and prosecution of anybody under the criminal trespass sections sections of law yeah I don't want to get hung up over this one piece.
I think this is so critical that we are getting housing providers and tenants' rights advocates coming together on this piece.
It provides a remedy for the housing providers to, in certain cases, use the 48-hour rule.
But I think this covers it.
In my opinion, I think we should move forward with that all right but um attorney layman go ahead to the mic a statement that said you can only enlist this judicial process that's being created after you've contacted law enforcement makes it sound like you sort of have to exhaust your remedies before you can go to court.
And it would create a predicate requirement that you contact law enforcement, see what they're going to do before you go into court.
I think the idea behind the proposal is to create additional avenues for people to get help and let them do it in any number of ways.
A lot of people aren't going to want to do a self-help remedy, so they'll call the police.
It's sort of a natural second step, but if you make it a necessary second step, you may be slowing them down instead of speeding them up, which is what this is trying to accomplish.
And at the same time, I'm thinking this is adding a step that doesn't need to be there.
By saying somebody's in your home, when you come home from vacation, you can either call the police and have them arrested, or you can get yourself a hotel room and just go to court on Monday or Tuesday morning and see if they can help you out.
I just think it's a step that we don't need to add.
With all due respect, Representative, I mean, I think your exact concern is what they're trying to address.
Nothing in this act shall be construed to extinguish any common law remedies, including self-help available to a non-rental owner.
I mean, whatever your existing rights are under case law to address someone you found in your home, which exists.
top of representative mcwilliams amendment i'm assuming this would go as a second sentence to your amendment mass other house representative sweden representative mcwilliams anything to add i think this proposal is sound the two sentences one um lines 22 22 and 23 in the McWilliams amendment and the proposed additional sentence that go together to be super clear without removing the non rental language.
okay so um i think we're almost there but i think we need tonight to massage the language a little bit more um so i believe we need to meet tomorrow at some point.
So we're going to take a break.
Do I take a break in this situation?
So what you want to do is recess and.
I'm recessing it tentative to Senator Bradley's schedule.
We can't quite do that.
You got to have a time certain.
So it's a House bill you get to determine.
Let let me i'm told 11 30 works um but that was what i was 11 30 might work let's give it a shot i'd probably almost rather have 12 30 but you want 12 30 30 yep Yeah.
1.30, that's fine fine I have a one o'clock and a 130 hopefully OLS can do the majority of the report I think the the two that I have at one and 130 are just looking at the language and making sure everything's dotted i's and cross t's okay so 12 30.
12 30 would be perfect okay i have um schedule kate um prepare the amendment if that's all right with you so the amendment is going to have everything we've discussed yeah today okay so i think it's three things the uh sentence that we provided and then um shall not require more than 1.5 residential parking spaces per unit for non-family not non-family, multi-family developments of 10 or more.
Then adding on to representative your language with the nothing in this section shall be construed.
And this language, the common law would go there in that sentence.
And I believe that's it.
and section five, the common law would go there in that sentence, and I believe that's it.
And Section 5, the word may should be shall have the right.
I think that we agreed to.
Okay.
So with that, we're going to recess this committee of conference until 1230 tomorrow, LOB 205-207 will be our room wonderful thank you everyone um don't forget